oh sorry welcome Bella yes because we
were already analyzing the game with
Bella so Bella you do like it here in
the studio yeah
oh three wins in a row like how does it
feel first of all especially after the
two defeats yes after the two different
it feels really good I think today I was
lucky so
it's good sometimes to be lucky well
it's yes it's a very nice feeling yes to
be on the other side of course but let's
have a look first at the opening your
opening Choice here uh night day six is
a very rare move did you prepare this
line or did you know it in advance no
actually I did not prepare the boss this
P3 Bishop at all I I missed somehow that
she is she's sometimes playing
this variation so here I played 96.
and
and then you decide probably it was not
a good decision
well in your defense we still even Chuck
played this move it's a very interesting
move of course but maybe your position
is a bit passive yes because
um I could not develop my pieces well
after this Exchange
oh
and you were forced to give up the
Bishops yes
yes
well I think that we all should admit
well we we have to admit that Nana
played this game very well and you
defend it very well you found the only
moves to stay alive in this game
so did you think about the sacrifice
first or not at all yes I was thinking
and actually I missed this idea to start
with the queen before Queen F6 otherwise
I had
um if we could start with Rook H1
probably I can play Rook E8
E5 so
this wasn't my idea okay
so
here Queen D4 is a very strong yeah
indeed and here G4
Rook H1 and we come this is the one like
probably the most critical moment of the
game Nana didn't give the check on HH
she took on D5 did you realize
immediately that the tables were turning
actually I was thinking about to see D5
and I thought that after Rook c72 it was
good for me
and what did you calculate after Rook h8
King D7 Queen takes so he's seven and I
was thinking even Queen G6 should be
better for white probably
um
yeah oh computer now well computer is
very happy okay he gave him the
possibility to breathe so oh yes Queen
f8 is a very strong continuation
so it's
it was a very beautiful gift and after
rookie seven of course black is
completely winning uh Bella it's
anyone's tournament now but tomorrow we
have a free day do you have something
planned for the free day yeah tomorrow
and after tomorrow I have to do three
days so I don't know exactly for now
probably I will come to see some
exhibition in the afternoon like maybe
then have a book in the town now that
you mentioned that you have another free
day because some bikaner withdrew from
the tournament how do you feel about it
um of course it's very sad I hope she
will be fine
um for the tournament it's not good but
sometimes it happens
thank you very much Bella and well hope
to see you in two days yes thank you
once again
our congratulations indeed three in a
row it always feels